the eyes to the right 333
the nose to the left 298
the eyes of it the eyes have it the lock
chancellor point mr speaker i recognize
the passion and conviction with which
many members spoke today in favor of the
0.7
target members who voted both for and
against the government's motion
in fact and to me that is the salient
point mr speaker
whilst not every member felt able to
vote for the government's compromise
the substantive matter of whether we
remain committed to the 0.7
target not just now but for decades to
come is clearly a point of significant
unity
in this house today's vote has made that
commitment more secure
for the long term whilst helping the
government to fix
the problems with our public finances
and continue
to deliver for our constituents today i
want to commit to the house mr speaker
that both i and the prime minister and
the foreign secretary
will continue to work with all
honourable members on how we can
continue to be a global leader helping
the world's
poorest on how to improve our aid
spending target it most effectively
and ensure that it is getting to those
who need it most
and mr speaker having now provided the
house with an effective vote on this
matter
the government will move forward with
its planned approach
[Music]